Hello Freak bitches. They hate it so
much cause it was humiliating and I,
it got a reaction out of him and I
just kept doing it. It means so much.
It was so much fun. And a lot of times
I, Anthony like at first hated it,
but then Anthony started to love it,
but then opie never loved it and it was
always kind of fun to do because I knew
like deep down it uncle Pauly hates.
So I would always don't go Paul just
to fucking make them sick because he
couldn't get with uncle
Paul Anthony of course.
Could you more comfortable now doing it
without him? The radio show much much.
Yo. Yeah, we stopped liking each other.
I mean the reality is we are, you know,
I know and I really mean that.
I always think I bad in his real life.
Like I don't want bad it
to happen to him, but, uh,
we simply stopped liking
each other. So, um, but he,
he was enjoying his afternoon show much
more without me. Then he was with me. Um,
I got the morning spa, spa
for whatever, you know. Um,
I think the company just was annoyed at
him or whatever they like to be in. Sam,
we're hungry, but his afternoon show
was good. I mean, uh, you know, he,
him and Shirod and those guys, they were
having fun so people didn't like it.
They didn't like it,
but he sounded like he was having fun and
he was loose on him. Fired. Like what,
what happened? What the
technical reason was, was um,
he had filmed Roland Campos,
our booker taking a shit.
Um, now I know, oop, well he
filled me doing it in 2009,
but he was being a goofball. You, I don't
think he was trying to be degrading,
just being an ass.
And then I'm showing it to,
I think a couple of the comics
and I guess, I don't know exactly,
I heard about it after the
ball had already been rolling.
So somehow Roland got nervous that he was
going to release it and maybe opie was
tea. I don't know what Robbie
said to him. I really don't.
But I think that it got back to one of
Rollins bosses and then the head of the
talent department spoke to them. And
then once human resources got involved,
then things change.
And I remember there was a clip of it
was getting bad and there was another
producer in the studio named Paul and
he was videotaping it and I think he had
been unrolling side and he thought
he was being a dick to him.
He's going to be a dick to
me. Nobody's like, yeah,
cause you chose Roland
in this whole thing,
like making it a public thing that was
really uncomfortable. And then Paul goes,
yeah, well I thought it was
wrong. And then Shirod goes
like, ah, he was having fun.
We all saw the tape, he was enjoying it.
He was laughing. And when I heard that,
I'm like, oh no, he just
said we all saw the tape.
So all the time like that just made it,
and again,
maybe they were going to fire him anyway.
I don't know.
Like they don't tell me that shit.
Um,
but he thinks that the
company was out to get him.
I don't know and again, I kind of
know what they said to him privately,
but to me he had two months left on his
deal and no company wants to fire you
two months out because of, because
of the potential lawsuits, lawsuits,
they would much rather let you ride
it out and then just not resign.
You will serious is in a weird
place because of podcasts. Yes.
I mean it's just in a very weird place
that the idea of paying money for these
talk shows that are going to get
interrupted by commercials and to have to
listen them only when they come
on and not have them on demand.
It's such an inferior distribution
where the online demand, like now,
now they're on demand is on your phone
an hour after it's up yet or an hour
after it's but live. You can listen
live on the phone and get it. Yeah.
What I'm saying is on your radio,
like if you're in your car and you,
you can't just pick,
I want to listen to Tuesdays opie and
Anthony Show or Jim Norton and Sam show.
I can't just pick that. I don't know if
you can, unless you have a phone hooked,
it might be a way to do with that phone
hooked up. Yeah, I think so. Yeah. Right.
But I don't think you could do that.
Like Sirius radio was only
playing what's playing right now.
I think so far I don't have car.
I mean I don't have a thing where
I could just pick an episode.
How has a podcast plate in a car you just
get, there's a bunch of different ways.
One, you can do it where you could
stream it live through youtube.
Some people do that and you just play
the audio and if you have it set up,
you can play the video. Some people do
it where you, uh, you're on stitcher.
Stitcher is a low bit rate version,
meaning it's a,
the audio quality's not as
good because it's compressed,
but it's way quicker to download.
So if you have some sort of a plan where
you want to get a less data per month,
a lot of people use stitcher or
they just get it off of iTunes.
But the thing about it is that you just,
if you have your phone Bluetooth up,
you literally,
all you have to do is press play and
it'll immediately play like whatever
episode. Like you want to scroll
through, scroll through our stuff.
I think if you go to work for Siri
now too on the new operating system,
just like ask for it. Yeah. You could
play it for Siri, but if you go through,
have you ever done, do you use it?
Do you use a iTunes or a podcast APP?
I never look at podcast
standing. All My, like my most,
the recent ones of all the ones that I
subscribe to and I can just take one,
click it and boom, now it's
playing. I mean that's just,
it's done differently on Sirius.
Yeah, the APP you have to use.
The on demand is pretty good,
but it's,
I think it's an hour after it as
you can get it forever. I feel good.
I don't listen. I don't really
listen to the shell. I mean,
I never listened to our show. Um, I
listened to it on drives and like, wow.
I kinda like it. Um, it's, it's new. We
find the Anthony back in the building,
I was allowed to come on as a
guest in our, in the building.
I fought for three years for that.
And literally right after he got fired,
they let him Anthony back in after,
I hope you got fired. He kept them.
I don't know. It could be
really honest. I don't know. Um,
I don't think that he actively kept him
out. No. Do they know the real numbers?
Like did they ever tell you how many
people were actually listening? Never.
I don't know if they know. I mean, I
don't know how they would track that.
They may,
but they don't and apply to me.
It's like I really want to know because
it will give us negotiating power.
I'd apply to me. He's like,
I really don't want to know,
but the fact that we're getting raises,
I think we're doing okay. Like I,
that's the only way I can tell is
that they, I know that they want to,
to keep me every time the contract is
okay. We must be doing okay. Um, but no,
I don't know what the numbers are.
Just it's amazing how quickly it became
a different thing. You know, like,
like I remember when Howard went
to serious, it was like, wow,
how Luhya finally we're going
to get uncensored radio.
And then it became,
well it's still just radio and still
it's still alive and now you have to pay
for it. Now it's 10 bucks a month
and mean he made out like a bandit.
I mean he made ridiculous sums of money
from it, but where's the future in that?
It just seems like that's a in, but
see it's like almost like investing in,
I mean if you're, if you're
someone who's got a piece of that,
it's like where's that going?
Like how are you going to keep,
you can't even use it in a tunnel.
You know, the thing we've series,
and this is this like a scary for
job security, but they really,
Scott is good at getting big name talent,
like a Beatles channel and all this
stuff and they're good at getting good,
good name, a big name, people doing
shows like Ferguson's on there.
And our channel. Yeah. I not a faction.
Um, where you guys are all in faction now.
Faction talk.
Yeah.
I hate the name cause it doesn't say
comedy but whatever it is what it is,
it's awesome. And then can we know
and rich and then Ellis and then uh,
Craig and then Nick Depalo who was
a very funny show. He's hilarious.
Nick is a fucking savagely funny guy.
I love that guy.
He's just a fucking raw fucking bark
out a joke. Funny Guy like nick is.
Here's the thing about nick,
he's never afraid to try to be funny.
Like I've done a lot of projects with
them. We get tough crowd for two years.
I've just done a shitload
of stuff back, back, back,
back like Nicholas fucking fire lines out.
And I've always admired him for
that because sometimes they work,
sometimes they don't,
but he's on a freight is a funny fucking
dude and he's unafraid to bark stuff
out and be who he is. Like I love
that. And he does a great show. Um,
he's a really surprisingly
good radio guy like,
but go into breaks and all that stuff.
But yeah,
Anthony's doing it for a long time
with Rd, remember? That's right. Yes.
I was on the charity show,
but I remember watching the one blow out
that they had or nick was trying to do
some read that they had already did.
Just wanted to kind of fuck off.
You can't let it get to you like that.
We've had the blowouts.
I've been through them. I've seen them,
me and that never had one. Um, I love man,
one of my fucking, I just wrote the
foreword to his book. I don't know.
I'm supposed to say that, but too bad.
I'm proud of it. I fucking love him.
And he's doing a show with
already now. Right? The AIA show
fucking greatest name.
They had a great billboard for it and a,
it's really funny man. It's really scrub
to listen to that. You do it for the,
to the compound. Yeah. How much does
that cost? I honestly don't know.
I do pay for it though. He offered
me a free one, but I'm looking at it.
I'll chime in. I mean I'll fucking,
I'll chip in and it's doing well. Frame.
That whole compound. Yeah.
He hasn't skipped a beat.
His life is fucking doing great.
Yeah.
There's not a great thing that both
their mugshots real legit mugshots
hilarious. They did it.
Yeah. Compound media.
I like how he called it compound media
too because, oh, look at the AIA show.
Great Posture Timber Fifth now
can you get that on your phone?
You can get it on an APP. I have the
Anthony coming into it in the car.
You can listen to it in the car. He's
a, but yeah, he's he, I love him too.
He's one of my favorite people ever.
He's literally somebody who I don't
think I'll ever not be close to.
There's no one created like I love Sam.
I love all these guys I've worked with,
but Anthony,
there was a weird,
it's a comic thing that happens when
you're going back and forth with some of
this in energy you're
exchanging and with him. Dude,
there are Jim Norton laugh compilations.
I never listen to my own shit.
I don't listen to the old show.
I can't listen to it,
but those I can listen to because they're
all in. Anthony just making me laugh.
It's not me saying funny shit.
It's Anthony saying funny shit
that every time fucking gets me.
Like he would literally make me laugh
like that wheeze laugh that an audience
member gets. I'm like, I never get to
fucking feel that way, but he's not even,
what's crazy is he's not a stand up.
He's not a standup.
He's done it a little bit,
but in that rolling. Yeah,
he tried it a couple of [inaudible] like
in Montreal a couple of years ago and
just do it. Yeah. After you'd been
fired. Oh my God. Yeah. No, no.
This would all be an Anthony.
We're supposed to do a show together
to host a comedy show in Montreal.
I was part of the show,
but I'll be at home for some reason.
He flew home a day early.
He didn't want to do it,
so aunties did it by himself and host
of the show and started shitting on the
comedians and he was really funny. First
time ever on stage. He was fucking funny.
But in a, in a comic room. Patrice
said that about him. He said,
he said Anthony can access funny faster
than any person I've ever seen and
Patrice didn't hand out.
You was not the known as the big Ole boy,
that Guy Dolan out compliments. Again,
like that was not, Patrice has reputation,
but Anthony has that ability to reach
in and grab funny from anywhere and he's
as fast as any comic we've ever had on it.
There's never been a comedian in
there who was faster than him.
They'd been as fast as him guys
like Patrice or burro genius,
but there's no one's ever been able
to go in there and run circles around
Anthony. Right. It's staggering how
fucking funny that guy. Yeah, it is weird.
It's like he's a comic
who never became a comic,
but that's how I've always felt about
being around them and even dice said that
about him and dice was shitting on opiate
Anthony when they had a few together.
He was saying that that Anthony's
actually talented and he's actually almost
like a comic, but he never
did it. He never did it.
And Anthony has an ability brewers
and amazing story teller to an amazing
storyteller. Whereas aunt could do that
about like, he could literally tell you,
he would talk about like,
you don't be in a tin knocker and stuff.
I have no knowledge of or interest in and,
and he would have me on the edge of my
seat listening to him talk about it.
He just has a gift for explaining
things and for walking you through it.
Louie has that the ability to explain
an amazingly interesting fashion and
Anthony can just jump in and out of
voices and do impressions. And I mean, I,
I never get sick of rambling about him
cause I got to work with them for a
fucking decade.
I got to work with the funniest guy
in the fucking world for a decade.
Like as much as it sucks that it's over,
like I'm grateful.
I just want to do it again.
100% of you thought about doing that and
I would love to do it with him and Sam,
I mean me and I'll be,
don't get along anymore. Um,
but I would love to have Anthony
with me and Sam. But again,
he's got his own show. It's not
going to happen, but I love salmon.
I have a very good chemistry
and a comfort level. Like I,
I like him and I trusted him on the
air and with LP it just got bad.
I'm not blaming him. It's like,
Hey, I was half the problem too.
But what about you doing a show
with Anthony? Compound media?
Shell compound media is to get it to a
more enclosed environment than Sirius's
and because of gigs and other things
I got to promote. I just Kinda,
I wanted to stay and also series pays
more and I didn't want to negotiate
against Anthony. I just
couldn't. I was like, Eh,
I wasn't going to use him as a
negotiation tactic. I didn't want to do,
I couldn't do it. Um, he's,
I'm too close to him and I always kind
of secretly wanted them to come back.
And when he came back the
first day he came back. I mean,
it was a messy in that fucking, I got the,
we went to a Springsteen. No. Who Played,
oh, guns and roses played at
the fucking, uh, the Apollo.
So this was like right
after you get fired.
So I saw Scott Greenstein that night
or Andrew and they're like, yeah,
he can come in. Anthony came in, I'm
like, really? They're like, yeah,
you can come in. And I'm like, great.
I texted him, come in tomorrow,
the minute he could come in and a,
but security hadn't been told.
So I'm on the show and we,
I know ants coming in.
It's gonna be a fucking
surprise for the audience,
but he's being held up at
security because in fairness,
they needed an email from
Scott. They didn't know that
had been okayed. Right. Had,
it took about an hour or 40 minutes, but
he got up and seeing him walk down that,
aw, fuck, it was so good. We'll
get them there. Yeah, he was happy.
You very rarely see that on his
face. It was so good. But, but you,
you just go right back into that.
And Sam is so perfect in that moment too.
Or you just kind of go back into
it and you flow and, you know,
so I miss him a lot,
but
okay.